what's goodie welcome back to hot breath
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros
that is your host guinness i am your
co-host
comedian joel byers and this channel is
all about helping you learn comedy from
the pros and become part of the next
generation of great comics i've
interviewed over 300 comedians on this
channel
and get a lot of questions from you and
a big one i keep getting is about
creating a tight five-minute set and
today's topic
is act outs it is adding
that extra dimension to your performance
so i have a few quick tips for you to
help you level up your type 5
and also a bonus one at the end all
about impression so the first
one is to show don't
tell a lot of the times we use a lot of
words
to describe something that we could
easily just perform or animate
instead and you don't have to be the
best actor i should say this all up for
you you don't have to be a trained actor
you don't have to be an actor
there are little cues you can do
that even if you aren't an actor you
don't do wild and crazy characters
there's little performance cues you can
do
to still add a new dimension and add
that acting
to your set so in showing and not
telling a big part is a lot of times we
may describe someone as
oh it was a a jovial a
rotund man who always came
in to work late um with his coffee
and he was panting because he ran inside
or whatnot
but what you could do instead is
actually if you're talking about
this rotund man you could
actually like physically show yourself
and that's
bill from work he always comes in late
like huff
huffing and puffing drinking his coffee
that you can actually instead of telling
us
what he's doing and how he looks while
doing it you can just show us
which takes me to the next point here
which is to actually
instead of narrating start acting
so a lot of the times we say this one
time at that one place so and so said
such and such to me
but a very effective way to actually
just take us to that moment the audience
is going to be way more connected when
it's in the present when you take us to
the scene
that you're describing to where you talk
to your co-worker
instead of saying oh last year at work i
saw bill come in late and i approached
him like hey bill you're late again and
he said well you know how i
am better late than never am i right
instead you could just take us to that
moment
and be like talking about work it'd have
to be a year ago you could
just say it just happened today or
whatever
and be say oh bill late again huh
well you know how i am that better late
than never
so both terrible act outs right there
but you can see
even as someone as terrible of an actor
as i am
just simple cues of saying a voice in
this direction looking in that direction
now signifies i'm speaking
saying the other voice in this direction
now notifies that
bill is speaking so just a simple
shift in your point of view
will indicate which character is talking
even if you can't throw your
voice and do actual characters so that's
a quick
way to even if you're not doing voices
looking this way one person speaking
while looking this way the other person
is speaking
is another way to do act out but the
biggest thing of all
in everything in my 11 years of comedy
what i have learned in doing act outs
the best tip is to start
incremental i always set a goal when i
do a set
of just a single goal of i want to try
this new punchline or i want to try this
new act out or on this joke
i'm just going to get absurd with the
character and see how much fun i can
have with it
and just start to build your act out
incrementally
go through your sets and in a previous
video i actually talked about
transcribing your sets to see where the
punch lines are
to where you can start editing them and
down but also go through your set and
see the opportunities to do
characters to bring in different voices
really start to look
through your set and how you can start
to add that extra dimension because it's
one thing
to really just be speaking and doing
your jokes
from this but when you actually start
bringing in your entire physicality
and start having that stage presence
that's when the jokes come to life and
that's when you really engage with the
audience
personal material is the perfect place
to start
and then when you bring in that personal
performance aspect to it
you're golden my friends so i hope that
really helps you in just a few minutes
here to just kind of
get out of that comfort zone of just
standing there reciting your jokes and
really starting to bring them to life
incrementally piece by piece now a lot
of people's is this bonus coming up
ask about impressions i've interviewed
several people who are really great at
impressions i'm personally not grading
impressions
but what i have learned from
interviewing so many people
is their number one tip is that you s
pick something specific about this
person
and then just exaggerate it for comedic
effects so if they have a funny voice or
if they're
rodney dangerfieldness hell ya i get no
respect
i think guinness is about tired of
watching me do these terrible
impressions
but you see it was rodney dangerfield
you kind of throw his voice a little bit
and do this exaggerating thing
it's just a very quick way to do
impressions so think about that when
you're doing your characters as well
even if you're not doing impressions
trying to figure out how to act out
someone think about something specific a
specific trait they have whether it's a
physical or vocal trait
and then just exaggerate it for comedic
effect it's a very
simple way to just add that new
energy into your set act outs really
bring an energy and a performance aspect
to your sets
that when you do see comics out there
really performing on stage and really
putting on
a show they all started somewhere and
they all started with first
learning the fundamentals and then
applying them
over time comedy is a marathon my
friends so just take these tips you hear
in this video
and our previous videos and all of our
interviews
and just apply things incrementally over
time
and in a few months of just incremental
shifts you're going to see a big
difference so i hope you found that
helpful
if you want to connect with me and
comics around the world in the hot
breath verse
go join our free facebook group where we
do all sorts of events and q and a's
and daily writing clubs all to help you
get better at comedy faster
we are all about being positive and
supportive and collaborative but
productive
you got to put in the work all of these
videos
that you watch on my channel or others
or you take courses or you read books
it only works if you do
now it's time to put in the work
go forth hop brother and sister and
apply these tips
leave a comment with your favorite tip
below and maybe how you're going to
apply to your next show
and i hope to see you in our facebook
group
dab on them guinness
get to work